[Music]
smell we know when it's good and we know
when it's bad but there's a woman in
Scotland I'm joining them who can smell
the unsmiling all my nose went on fire
joy Milne is the only known person who
can smell Parkinson's disease I have an
extremely sensitive sense of smell I can
smell it
meanly on the forehead and the back of
the neck to Joy it has a greasy musky
odor it is just a heavy smell to me she
first noticed it on her late husband les
Milne 12 years before he was diagnosed I
just thought he was tired and he wasn't
shouting enough it wasn't very welcome
of course me saying to mug you're
smelling it wasn't until she attended a
conference with other Parkinson's
patients that she realized the smell was
something more when I walked into the
room I saw gosh these other people smell
the same as last us at the end of the
meeting I stood up and said why were
they not investigating the smell of
Parkinson's no-one was investigating
because no one else could smell it
researchers set up a controlled
experiment to test Joy's nose she was
asked to distinguish a set of t-shirts
worn by those with and without the
disease she insisted one of the subjects
in the control group had the musky scent
the man rang about eight months later
and said I've got Parkinson's so I had
pre diagnose somebody by the time most
people are diagnosed 80 to 90 percent of
the damage is done
so Joy's mission is to help scientists
improve early detection methods
if they can find these people earlier it
would stop this anguish some people say
it smells like decaying garbage or
rotten meat or smelly feet but nope it's
stinky tofu stinky tofu has been
fermented and gives off an intense smell
while mostly found as a street food
throughout China here in Taipei one
woman has given the state of home what a
means of Jojo who should be was
synthesis Chi Chi Chi Chi
puto Cesare Total Drama pick you to
system don't you the Chancellor oh yeah
Ivan I thought she didn't have a cola na
vomit ideas in yeah totally Ella ah
hydrate epochal told not your deleted in
soldier soap on here and a good stink
all starts with a good brine was it
Fonda China say no homo kill you shall I
the nato-russia now and daughter
granddaughter on the can and the suicide
Nia anatomical Chile
someone not entirely intact young fun
way Todd strepa job or no medium for
tiny Tina trading 30 soon
mm how a on yonder to Noir
mmm
[Music]
no ganja hi Angie how'd you burn - g.b.m
felt it half way she saw 2008 Joe pass
she saw the tree Victoria power patio
you a talk show you a nun and for miss
Wu it's not only about the taste
wait'll ya see ya back then Silla
senator welcome you answer the door soon
Oh Paterson TV AHA here it has a face on
shower you need a shower
he says how were you when he wasn't well
and Jacqueline tell me Luke oh sure if I
see how she nodded assent e-wrap all
partied out but for most of Taiwan it's
about the taste
wake up and personal sit up and talk
hisses yah-yah-yah butan mad man went on
shinza told us just a woman by one store
she rather eaten Precision's moral of
the story don't judge a dish by its
stink
this is uni a two-year-old binturong
[Music]
with a face like a cat a body like a
bear and a tail like a monkey these
reclusive creatures are unlike any other
binturongs are native to the tropical
rainforests of Southeast Asia and spend
most of their time high in the treetops
they are excellent climbers their long
prehensile tails act as another limb as
they move through the trees even when
asleep their tails are anchored securely
around a branch the binturongs
flexibility doesn't end there their
ankles can rotate 180 degrees to
maintain their grip even when climbing
down a tree headfirst
perhaps the most curious trait at the
binturong
is it smelled buttered popcorn while
pleasing to a human knows the binturongs
scent is a way to mark its territory and
to warn rivals to move along
the binturong faces many threats the
worst being habitat destruction over the
past two decades their population has
fallen precipitously this is the
binturong in the French Riviera lies a
medieval town that's held one industry
it's very hard for the last 300 years
this is grass this is the world's
capital of perfume this is the city of
cents
yes
Vasquez was a scientist here
the perfume we breasts are the
collective disparity we are at risk
ammonia some of the big names that come
from here like Chanel Chanel number five
do of course and Louie Vuitton it's
something that's understood here it's a
community it's a language it's something
that people share as a map example
Zubair as a simple each other houses the
three Cristiano da Matta Mia I attend
upon me activity was a Gaza was Allen
told this I need is recent currently
distancing country policy senior
satisfaction was to the parlor floor his
own in the Flores own sillerton we're
also three large only normal away Lili
Korea's vallavan career move dhikr
sickly on violin and gas only Madonna
suck
it's a violinist real by histochemistry
no satisfaction the ferry new pollution
under threat Rio de Gama la cultura de
la jolla Suzuki Rafi should be continued
and called keiko sunny passages and
lungs
Sh'ma porphyria in body on a permanent
new opposite distraction Duras an
element in every dunker to jockey
Canisius College University estamos aquí
lo confabulate positive elevated head
coach a gentleman available on
deliveries on the world
yeonbok Rudy Danny reporter mr. ravine
Raymond Daniel Attah giveth a
concentration in a Napoleonic unit loads
physician group of young hero dextry a
generic anyone and pretty rapidly
extremely to the campaign conservative
Vasily Tampa is answer very fast for a
prophecy my name is Jessica Buchanan and
I am an independent perfumer I came to
grass for a perfumery school so what I
do is in very simple context mixing
together raw materials for various
different uses whether it's a perfume
that one would wear to for example a
candle I think to create a good perfume
I like to allow six months to a year
this is a very creative process when I
sit in front of the perfumers organ and
create it's like sitting in front of a
piano and composing music yeah I think
there's something in the air here
[Music]
in my work I really tried to reproduce
smell scenarios for different purposes
be it Street be the neighborhood in the
city I've done cause and so smell all
over the world could we on behalf of a
small molecule find out something about
history but we otherwise would know this
is sisal Tallis she has many things an
artist a scientist but more importantly
a smell expert she however prefers
another title i'm call myself a
professional in-betweener
which means what exactly there's a whole
world to smell and the whole word to
indicate how to smell so you cannot just
limit yourself to one discipline right
the point is she has dedicated her life
to the sense of smell what it means that
how it can be used to better understand
the world and each other pretty early in
my life I started ask questions why are
we only understanding the world on
behalf of how the world look like what
if we started using other senses more
appropriate for the same purpose
oh my web is starting to discover the
same world I've been looking at for
several years using the nose for the
purpose so how exactly did you go about
recording and then reproducing these
smells I will walk around identify
smells with my own nose I have small
devices that enable me to collect the
smell Malika's emitting from the source
with the result I go to my lab and then
the data I get is them the starting
point of reproduction of the actual
smell I have a lab consisting of up to
4,000 chemical compounds and with those
ingredients as with those compounds
literally reproduce invisible reality
that surround you full time all the time
name a city a neighborhood within a
neighborhood a historical building or
even an era in time and most likely
sizzle has reproduced that smell along
with thousands of other scents here in
her lab with the hopes of using the
findings for a bigger purpose the
purpose can be tolerance education
navigation to memorize the list is
endless is more interesting if you
really start on the sender's mouth and
see how you can use that information for
a purpose beyond miss mallison
[Music]
most people think this fruit smells
terrible it's been described using words
like rotting onions or raw sewage not
this guy though it's a very good smell
to me my name is Chang tak seng the
comedian Singh I'm a farmer
until now nearly 30 years selling urine
decided called me during segments if
you're not that familiar with durian it
has a spiky rind and the inside is a
yellow soft colored creamy fruit it's
native to Southeast Asia and because of
its odor is actually banned from many
public places urine is forbidden in a
pond in hotel some places they put a
sign age that no odor and allow the
smell
you can hide my record is about 100 feet
I can smell you red
besides having a distinctive smell
durian also has a distinctive taste it's
like a peanut caramel they have five
flavor sweet flavor alcohol flavor
bitter flavor flower flavor and nantes
total of five flavor numb taste
literally means your mouth will go numb
wow I can feel the numbness freshly
dropped Duran
the flavor is so good even the bees come
to the near end this might well be my
new favorite fruit people in general are
divided on this group
those who love it love it the durian is
so tasty
it's much better than it smells if you
really like Duran there can be like some
people may look like crazy like
breakfast lunch dinner
treemail are ordering they can eat five
seven fruits per day and there are
others who just can't get past the smell
I smell like Oh what they chase for
durian saying it is the perfect fruit
either you like it or you hate some
people they don't give chance to taste
but people to try once in your lifetime
[Music]
little treats
there are rearview mirrors staple
protecting noses from offensive odors
all over the world but where do they
come from
[Music]
over sixty years ago a scientist by the
name of Julius Amon had a chance
encounter with a milkman that changed
the course of the air freshener game
forever it was in Watertown New York a
milkman was making the rounds when he
stopped to speak to Julius a German
Jewish chemist who fled the Nazis and
studied out pine tree aromas in the
forests of Canada said milkman began
venting to Julius about the stench that
spoiled milk left in his car and thus
the quest began to destroy bad car odors
Julius drew inspiration from the tree
aromas he studied by infusing their oils
onto paper in 1954 he filed a patent for
tree shaped paper infused with powder
destroying air perfume Julius then
started producing the air fresheners out
of an empty auto shop and sending
samples to local gas stations the little
trees were a big hit and Julius
successfully created the first
automotive air freshener though the look
remains the same the scents are forever
changing now the little tree company has
over 60 cents and has sold over a
billion little trees worldwide